[Music]
cell membranes are structures of
contradictions these oily films are
hundreds of times thinner than a strand
of spider silk yet strong enough to
protect the delicate contents of life
the cells watery cytoplasm genetic
material organelles and all the
molecules it needs to survive how does
the membrane work and where does that
strength come from
first of all it's tempting to think of a
cell membrane like the tight skin of a
balloon but it's actually something much
more complex in reality it's constantly
in flux
shifting components back and forth to
help the cell take in food remove waste
let specific molecules in and out
communicate with other cells gather
information about the environment and
repair itself the cell membrane gets
this resilience flexibility and
functionality by combining a variety of
floating components in what biologists
call a fluid mosaic
the primary component of the fluid
mosaic is a simple molecule called a
phospholipid a phospholipid has a polar
electrically charged head which attracts
water and a non-polar tail which repels
it they pair up tail to tail in a two
layer sheet just five to ten nanometers
thick that extends all around the cell
the heads point in towards the cytoplasm
and out towards the watery fluid
external to the cell with the lipid
tails sandwiched in between this bilayer
which at body temperature has the
consistency of vegetable oil is studded
with other types of molecules including
proteins carbohydrates and cholesterol
cholesterol keeps the membrane at the
right fluidity
it also helps regulate communication
between cells sometimes cells talk to
each other by releasing and capturing
chemicals and proteins the release of
proteins is easy but the capture of them
is more complicated that happens through
a process called endocytosis in which
sections of the membrane engulf
substances and transport them into the
cell as vesicles
once the contents have been released the
vesicles are recycled and returned to
the cell membrane
the most complex components of the fluid
mosaic are proteins one of their key
jobs is to make sure that the right
molecules get in and out of the cell
nonpolar molecules like oxygen carbon
dioxide and certain vitamins can cross
the phospholipid bilayer easily but
polar and charged molecules can't make
it through the fatty inner layer
transmembrane proteins stretch across
the bilayer to create channels that
allow specific molecules through like
sodium and potassium ions peripheral
proteins floating in the interface of
the bilayer help anchor the membrane to
the cells interior scaffolding other
proteins in cell membranes can help fuse
two different by layers that can work to
our benefit like when a sperm fertilizes
an egg but also harm us as it does when
a virus enters a cell
and some proteins move within the fluid
mosaic coming together to form complexes
that carry out specific jobs for
instance one complex might activate
cells in our immune system then move
apart when the job is done
cell membranes are also the site of an
ongoing war between us and all the
things that want to infect us in fact
some of the most toxic substances we
know of are membrane breaching proteins
made by infectious bacteria
these pore-forming toxins poke giant
holes in our cell membranes causing a
cell's contents to leak out
scientists are working on developing
ways to defend against them like using a
nano sponge that saves ourselves by
soaking up the membrane damaging toxins
the fluid mosaic is what makes all the
functions of life possible without a
cell membrane there could be no cells
and without cells there would be no
bacteria no parasites no fungi no
animals and no us head Eadie has the
good fortune of collaborating with
brilliant animators from all over the
world and sometimes the beauty and
complexity of their work is best
appreciated in small discreet Lewton as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
you